our profiles in service series
highlights Americans who dedicate their
lives to helping others this morning we
are focusing on the only two female
battalion Chiefs in the Washington DC
fire department
Keisha Clemente Shia and Queen anoon a
are pioneers in a department of more
than eighteen hundred firefighters their
goal is to give back to the city where
they grew up
Jan Crawford met up with them and joins
us from a Washington DC firehouse Jan
good morning well good morning Nora so
you know when Keisha Clemenza and Queen
Anne una joined the Washington DC fire
department there were 1500 firefighters
with just 35 of them were women now more
than two decades later these two women
have risen through the ranks and helped
change the face of the city's finest
public servants every year firefighters
in the nation's capitol protects some
700,000 residents and more than 20
million visitors from around the world
we show up it's your worst day and it's
our responsibility to help you out on
your worst day Italian fire chief's
Queen a new name Keisha Clemenza say the
job is tough on anyone you have to have
the spirit of giving you can't have
never run never competed in sports this
is what you will call a professional
athlete you've got to be physically
strong and mentally strong absolutely
you're going to see things it's going to
be devastating to you that's going to
last in your memory forever it's how you
deal with that everyone doesn't fly
airplanes not everybody's gonna run into
burning building for women there are
other challenges a man can walk in the
firehouse for the first time and they
will look at them and assume that they
can do their job until they prove
otherwise
when Iced females walking for our house
they assume that we can't until we prove
other
the Chiefs learn that lesson soon after
joining the department in the early 90s
once you get out of training academy and
you realize when you go out into the
companies they all know your name the
members know where you're getting a
female assigned at so at that point I
knew the seriousness and that we were
minorities true minorities to some
people did you get the sense I think you
shouldn't be there less than four
percent of firefighters nationwide are
women and the largely all-male
environment has at times fostered
discrimination
more than half of the women firefighters
surveyed nationwide report feeling
shunned or isolated and 43 percent said
they experienced verbal harassment I had
some rough times when I was accused just
sleeping around before the firefighters
in one house that must have been
extremely hurtful it fury ated me so
much that it motivated me to do more and
for me my revenge was success a new ney
says you show women belong by doing your
job well I think if I'm here and I'm not
representing myself as a professional
and changing the climate for women
officers and I haven't done my job I'm
here to make things better to become
only the third female battalion chief in
the department's a hundred and
thirty-five year history a new nailin on
her mentor DC's first female firefighter
B rudder seeing her in position even in
1991 where there weren't many women it
was inspiring and when I talked with her
I said I'm gonna be in charge one day
she said well you better know your stuff
good morning good morning a new name now
oversees 50 firefighters at six fire
houses and is passing on that same
encouragement to the next generation is
she tough she's a really tough chief she
cuts me knows the back Jasmine Jones who
graduated from the Academy in January
still fears some say the firehouse is no
place for a woman they think I can't do
it so you just have to prove them wrong
give them a reason to be like we need
more women like you to want to do this I
think we do the job better than the guys
anyway you stuck here naysayers
absolutely absolutely that will never go
away what's their argument that we
didn't earn it that we don't deserve it
oh they're giving us this position
because of the climate of women and
empowerment so I'm like okay with that's
your opinion that's your opinion I know
what I've done to get to this point
I love you bracelet because like you
said you know it takes a bad female to
being a fire department now as these two
women get close to retirement they're
also having some other personal goals a
new name is hoping to continue changing
the culture couraging women to join the
department and Excel and clemency a well
she's looking to keep advancing up the
ranks and break even more glass ceilings
for women Gail Jan love them both
throughout the piece we're going oh
that's good that's good that's good
my revenge is success I love that Keisha
and I love what Queen said when we show
up it's your worst day but yet they show
up they run in when most of us are
running out very nice Thank You Jan